I tell my kids who were alive when it
opened started coming up any sandwich
they loved the movie and I saw that
because ironically for time travel movie
had timelessness Atene existed apart
from its period it resonated with
younger audiences and and that's just I
just went wild it's gonna be around for
a long time
yeah it's kids like it my kids I haven't
watched it there
really I don't think so if they hadn't
told me about it
they were just watching it in secret hey
Josie
I wish I had I wish I had a real a gag
reel of how many times I had clipped by
that freaking door the Dorian door you
said to take after take of you whack I
do it and then I get inside it and then
they handle the flux capacitor and all
that stuff there and in order to drive
it it was the worst thing to drive I had
two gears and it was and I slam it
forward in my hand with smashing that
flux capacitor my hand would be bleeding
my hidden be bleeding and I had to clean
all up to get to the family ties set an
IV backstage and family ties make my
entrance and and going where's my
where's my camcorder and I'm looking for
props from Back to the Future here I
almost called them a Meredith Baxter doc
you know I like my mom but I do remember
getting I mean I seriously if I had a
clip of every memory I'd hit by the door
it would be like 30 seconds of whack
whack
so I people say what would it take to
get in the Dorian again I said what
Marty would have been money without
within a mentor the darkness is mentor
and then and a way to channel his energy
and then into into curiosity but things
in exploration and discovery in and
seeing that everything isn't as it
appears to be like this piece of junk
can be part of this piece of junk which
in an opening can a can of dog food how
this piece of knob can contain two up to
eleven well Danny just use the fact that
all things are possible
mm-hmm well because when you're when
you're when you're 18 17 years old in
high school I mean a lot of things don't
seem possible and you're kind of running
up against what you can't do and who you
aren't and where you don't fit in and
and and so to have this just mentor this
guy who was not not like every other
adult he knew yeah but was was really
special and and invited him to share his
ideas and and in his adventures I mean
really I mean I'm sure resonated with
people that age that they were looking
for people to accept him as they weren't
Santa include them in the plans yeah
are you playing the same with anybody by
Chris did wherever you're all fantasy
and science fiction film fans you know
that any fantasy story or any myth we
would have built on certain rules if
there's magic powers they work it's
under these circumstances or this has to
happen or you have to get the rock from
the stone or whatever so there's a lot
of exposition a lot of piping you got
you gotta yet explain that to the
audience and sometimes it's really
tedious and hard to do and and Chris is
such a brilliant actor if he was able to
all that stuff that he was saying as doc
he was explaining how the film work he's
explaining how the story worked and what
and made it possible for everyone to get
on board and enjoy it it's like he said
excuse me for the crudeness of this this
model and then and it was that amazing
model of the the Clocktower the same
thing he kind of crazy and rambling but
it all is brilliant and and he just I've
never seen anything I've never seen an
actor be able to do that my life I've
never seen an actor as good with
exposition and making it entertaining
and in and and fascinating and fun to
watch he's genius
you
that crew she kind of goes with with
with what we was just saying that that
that and I know said today we really
filled me up with with with a warm
feeling that here oh you guys are
happier dressed as other people and
other characters and maiming crazy
costumes and stuff but you're the most
genuine real people I've ever met I mean
I met I met one after another and I just
thought these people with a heart on the
sleeves and love what they love and love
being together and love doing the things
that they enjoy and that's it that's a
nerd that's what marty is so Barney -
nerd guys one of us one of us
probably the first one just because it
was it was such an overwhelming
experience it was like I said doing the
show in the end and and the movie at the
same time but but you just step in with
these amazing people it's this cast and
then Bob and everybody ain't really kind
of he just I mean I was at I was just
about 5 to 6 years removed me a kid in
Canada like he's you know thinking I was
going to work on the fish docks or beat
during the army like my dad or do
something and it all set him on a set
with Steven Spielberg and Bob Zemeckis
and and these amazing actors of doing
this amazing story it just was one of
those things where you wanted to pinch
yourself but you didn't want to wake up
yeah it just was an amazing experience
you